oh well whatever you've got planned for
thanksgiving today um hopefully you've
already got the oven on at least maybe
you're doing the pies or
some of the casseroles or something john
doesn't like casseroles oh well
it's more for you guys that's right for
us yeah you do lots of good cat mac and
cheese casserole broccoli casseroles you
can do lots of good casseroles john
you're missing out all right so we're
not going to miss those north winds as
soon as they calm down we're looking at
the airport things look pretty good
right now yesterday 30 plus mile an hour
winds now if you're in laughlin it's
still pretty windy and we're going to
keep those north winds wind advisory has
actually been extended there mountain
springs summit between prump and las
vegas still pretty bumpy up there as
well lots of 40's around the valley this
morning it's chilly so turn that oven on
get it going and enjoy 33 at red rock
and 24 up there at kyle canyon the
backside of the spring mountains pretty
windy as well this morning look at reno
23 tone upon below freezing ely's going
down already down to seven degrees 18 in
caliani cedar city they're opening at
bryan head for skiing today they only
have two runs but at least they're
opening and 35 in mesquite 30s for
pahrump and indian springs 40 in
searchlight 54 in laughlin with those
winds boulder city at 45 and kingman at
34
under a freeze warning but temperatures
really close to freezing buttery
sunshine for our thanksgiving with mid
to low 60s today we've got a warming
trend though on the way we'll get into
some nice low 70s sunny skies into the
weekend and december starts off
with record highs
our high for december 1st could tie the
record next week i'll show it to you in
the eight day forecast showers from the
great lakes all the way down to the gulf
coast they'll continue to march all the
way and slide east fortunately it looks
like new york city will get the parade
in before the rain but cranberry texas
just i mean cranberry pa that's north of
pittsburgh 46 degrees with some showers
around turkey texas 37 this morning it's
been somewhat cloudy
shaking the tail feathers there to stay
warm back here at home that wind
advisory does continue until six o'clock
for the lake and the river if you're
headed there and our afternoon boy
gobbles a buttery sunshine with low 60s
tom turkey yep saying happy thanksgiving
everybody enjoy and the evening walk's
going to be chilly in the 50s mid 60s
tomorrow hanukkah begins sunday evening
beautiful day on sunday in the 70s and
look at 74 on wednesday that is the
record high for december 1st it looks
like we may tie it john